österreich hat gewählt die svp von
ex-kanzler kurz blicken hochrechnungen
klar vorn
aber wer wird koalitionspartner wieder
proteste in moskau zehntausende
oppositionelle demonstrieren und fordern
die freilassung inhaftierter mitstreiter
mercedes doppelsieg in sotschi lewis
hamilton gewinnt den großen preis von
russland sebastian vettel scheidet aus
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend seien sie
willkommen bei unseren
nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag den
sport hat uns wiederholt fahnen
mitgebracht hallo und guten an die
wahllokale in österreich sind seit 17
uhr geschlossen sieger und verlierer der
nationalratswahl stehen schon recht
sicher fest vp und grüne konnten viele
stimmen hinzugewinnen dfb hat nach ihrem
skandal um das strache video auf ibiza
und neuen korruptionsvorwürfen massiv
verloren
er ist der strahlende sieger ex-kanzler
sebastian kurz seine konservative vp
konnte im vergleich zur wahl vor zwei
jahren noch einmal deutlich zulegen
der wahlkampf des 33-jährigen mit dem
fokus auf wirtschaftsfragen scheint
aufgegangen zu sein
jetzt kann er sich seinen künftigen
koalitionspartner aussuchen
aus wien wolf christian ullrich es ist
ein triumph für sebastian kurz
riesenjubel bei der vp für den alten und
wohl auch neuen bundeskanzler sind als
bundesregierung im mai abgewählt worden
es waren schwere vier monate und heute
hat uns die bevölkerung zurück gewählt
vielen vielen dank
tapfer klatschen spd anhänger dagegen
die herben verluste weg ibiza affäre
unter jungs spesenskandal bedeuten jetzt
pole positionen
das interpretieren wir nicht als in den
auftrag diese regierung fortzusetzen
leider die övp käme nach der orf
hochrechnung auf 37,1 prozent die
sozialdemokraten auf 21,8 die fpö nur
noch auf 16
die grünen auf 14 die liberalen eos auf
7,8 und die sonstigen auf zwei prozent
enttäuschung über das ergebnis bei der
spd doch keine personellen konsequenzen
heißt es aus der parteispitze
trotz des schlechten abschneidens von
spitzenkandidatin rendi wagner
wasserpegel mehr vorgestellt haben gut
gekämpft aber die leute haben unsere
botschaft nicht bei dem grünen riesen
jubel die klimadebatte sorgte für das
größte politische comeback in österreich
nach dem krieg vor zwei jahren aus dem
parlament geflogen jetzt womöglich sogar
kandidat für regierungsbeteiligung mit
diesem ergebnis werden die
koalitionsverhandlungen spannend ein in
der tat britta hilpert vor der
parteizentrale der vp wohin geht die
reise jetzt mit welcher koalition
rechnen sie in wien
ich rechne vor allen dingen erst mal mit
langen koalitionsverhandlungen denn
rechnerisch ist hier zwar viel möglich
aber mit allen potenziellen partnern es
ist schwierig mit dem alten
koalitionspartner der
rechtspopulistischen fpö wird es deshalb
schwierig weil die skandal erschüttert
nun erstmal mit sich selbst zu tun hat
einen spitzenvertreter sagte außerdem
nach zehn prozentpunkten verlusten
sehen sie den wählerauftrag für
regierungsarbeit nicht mehr
die sozialdemokraten halten sich zwar
noch zurück mit einer koalitionsaussage
während vielleicht sogar zu haben aber
die große koalition ist in österreich
traditionell sehr unbeliebt die grünen
die überraschungssieger des abends
könnten mit ihren 14 prozent sebastian
kurz die mehrheit bringen aber ein
spitzenvertreter sagte eben mit dieser
svp könne sich eine koalition überhaupt
nicht vorstellen
und zu guter letzt die liberalen neos
haben einfach nicht genügend eingefahren
es werden also auf jeden fall zähe und
lange verhandlungen für sebastian kurz
der strahlende sieger muss sich auf eine
lange koalitions verhandlungszeit
einstellen
vielen dank peter nach wien nach der
kritik an euro und zuwanderung will die
afd den kampf gegen die
klimaschutzpolitik zu ihrem dritten
hauptthema machen
diese sei maßlos und völlig ineffektiv
sagte parteichef gauland der welt am
sonntag
alle anderen parteien würden so wörtlich
den irrsinn mitmachen den greta
schönberg angeheizt habe als sie bei der
uno ausgerastet sein
in moskau hat die liberale opposition
ihre proteste vom sommer wieder
aufgenommen mehr als 20.000
schon kam zu einer kundgebung die dieses
mal genehmigt war
sie fordern die freilassung von
bürgerrechtlern den nach verbotenen
demonstrationen zu mehrjähriger
lagerhaft verurteilt worden waren für
begabt berichtet ihr habt dafür gesorgt
dass wir frei kommen und jetzt sorgen
wir gemeinsam dafür dass auch alle
anderen freigelassen werden
valérie kostenlos ist einer von
tausenden die bei demonstrationen für
faire wahlen im sommer festgenommen
worden waren
die meisten kamen schnell wieder frei
andere wurden in fragwürdigen
gerichtsprozessen zu mehrjährigen
haftstrafen verurteilt
wir dürfen nicht länger schweigen wir
dürfen die ungerechtigkeit nicht länger
hinnehmen
jeder beschwert sich dass das regime
falschen dass eine tyrannei herrscht
aber niemand wehrt sich wirklich camel
kritiker alexej nawalny tritt zuletzt
nur noch selten auf demonstrationen auf
schon oft wurde er festgenommen
heute hielt er eine rede in der
präsident putin scharf angriff gleich
mehrere anführer verschiedene meist
liberale strömungen hatten zum heutigen
protest aufgerufen
das ist ungewöhnlich denn russlands
opposition gilt als hoffnungslos
zersplittert die opposition vereinigt
jetzt dass wir einer gemeinsamen
bedrohung gegenüber stehen der
politischen verfolgung leute werden
unter dem vorwurf des extremismus
verhaftet sowohl aus dem linken als auch
aus dem rechten lager ab morgen finden
mehrere berufungsverfahren für die im
sommer verhafteten statt die 25.000
moskauer die heute auf der straße waren
hoffen dass ihr protest zu gerechten
urteilen führt
demonstrationen heute auch wieder in
hongkong gegen die chinesische regierung
und gegen polizeigewalt
die proteste waren wieder nicht
genehmigt und von gewalt überschattet
kurz vor den siebzigsten jahrestag der
gründung der volksrepublik sind auch
hunderte anhänger pekings auf die straße
gegangen
sie forderten eine friedliche feier des
jahrestags einmal zum mond oder mars und
bitte auch wieder zurück das us
unternehmen spacex hat ein neues
raumschiff vorgestellt das bis zu 100
menschen und eine grosse fracht
mitnehmen kann
damit könnten stützpunkte auf dem mond
gebaut werden oder gar städte auf dem
mars so space ex schon in der
vergangenheit hatte firmenchef musk
hochfliegende pläne präsentiert das
raumschiff solle ab 2025 die ersten
menschen zum roten planeten bringen
außerdem sei es wieder verwendbar der
sport heute mit einer wm goldmedaille
für eine deutsche kanutin rudi genau
wird am letzten wettkampftag hat zwar
noch mal geklappt überraschende erfolg
für andrea herzog bei den kanu slalom
weltmeisterschaften in spanien
die 19 jährige leipzigerin gewann gold
im canadier
die jüngste im team feiert den grössten
erfolg andrea herzog gewinnt gold im
canadier einer
die 19-jährige sechs ihn ist im finale
schnell und vor allem fehlerfrei
unterwegs sie kann befreit fahren denn
den so wichtigen quotenplatz für olympia
und ihren eigenen startplatz hat herzog
bereits im halbfinale erkämpft ihr gold
ist die einzige deutsche medaille bei
diesen weltmeisterschaften ein
versöhnlicher abschluss für die
slalom-kanuten lewis hamilton hat den
großen preis von russland in sotchi
gewonnen schon der neunte saisonsieg für
den führenden in der wm-wertung zweiter
wurde hemden teamkollegen valtteri
bottas vorschalten le claire sebastian
vettel musste sein ferrari mit einem
defekt abstellen nachdem er zu beginn
des rennens in führung gelegen hatte im
ersten sonntagsspiel der fußball
bundesliga gewinnt freiburg mit 2 1 in
düsseldorf die freiburger sind damit
tabellendritter nur einen punkt hinter
spitzenreiter bayern
maz petersen ist der neue straßen
radweltmeister der däne gewann das
rennen im dauerregen in der britischen
grafschaft yorkshire nach 261 kilometern
vor dem italiener trennt ihn und dem
schweizer küng degenkolb landete als
bester deutscher auf platz 15 und zu
nachtschlafender zeit und fast ohne
zuschauer haben die gea bei der
leichtathletik wm in doha ihren 50
kilometer wettbewerb absolviert
sonntagmorgen 334 der neue die weltweite
yu suzuki kommt aus japan nach vier
stunden 4 minuten und 20 sekunden nie
war eine zeit bei einer wm langsamer er
war bei hitze und luftfeuchtigkeit
indoor der beste deutsche karl dohmann
auf platz 7 während der neue weltmeister
liegen feiert das beste deutsche wm
resultat auf der längsten aller
leichtathletik strecken seit zehn jahren
und morgen wieder leichtathletik bei uns
im zdf ab 16.05 danke rudi bleibt noch
das wetter im norden bewölkt mit
schauern im süden mehr sonne und meist
trocken
stürmischer westwind dem osten und dem
bergland mit orkanartigen böen 14 bis 20
grad und die weiteren aussichten am
dienstag im südosten sonnig und warm im
norden dauerregen ab der wochenmitte
überall wechselhaft
kühler so das war's morgen begrüßt sie
wieder christian sievers an dieser
stelle danke für ihr interesse einen
schönen sonntagabend noch und bleiben
sie dran für berlin direkt und theo koll